august is here which means it's time for
another animal crossing update video
we've got a few new bugs and fish to
talk about as well as another free
content update from nintendo
let's dive in people of the internet
retro racket tour here and welcome back
to another animal crossing new horizons
video
if this is your first time here our
channel is all about bringing people
together through the power of video
games
first up let's talk about the new
content update and what all nintendo has
added if you're just here for the new
bugs and fish go ahead and skip to
this point in the video for the rest of
you let's dive into the content update
overall it's not as much as the july
update but there are still some things
here that are sure to please die hard
fans of the game
including me arguably the biggest
addition this month is the return of
dream suite for those who have been away
from the animal crossing series for a
while
like me or perhaps this is your first
animal crossing game period
dream suite was first introduced in
animal crossing new leaf
dream suite is a welcome feature to new
horizons as it gives you the ability
to visit islands of other players
without them needing to be
online at the time every player will
have their own unique dream address
which you can share with others
in fact here's my code now if you'd like
to make a visit to retro land and check
out the retro land theme
park anytime you want to get started
simply lay in a bed inside your house
you should actually have a free bed from
luna in your mailbox after updating the
game but any bed will do
after laying down on the bed you'll get
a prompt asking if you want to sleep
say yes and then you'll enter a dream
state there you'll meet luna who'll tell
you how everything works to get your own
dream address that you can share with
others tell luna
i'd like to share a dream of course
you'll need to be connected to the
internet for this to work
don't worry about writing down the code
though because after luna gives you your
dream address
it will also appear on your passport and
map now you can share that dream address
with anyone you wish
if you want to visit other islands the
process starts the same way talk to luna
but this time choose the
want to dream option from there you'll
input the dream address you'd like to
visit
note that there are some limitations
when you're visiting islands via a dream
address
you'll be free to explore the island
talk to villagers and this is the big
one here
download custom designs unfortunately
you won't be able to fish catch bugs
use the item shop or learn any diys
in addition to dream suite the august
update also brings a firework show every
sunday at 7 pm local time
i'm sure you'll also be delighted to
know that we can now back up
our islands finally it's a shame that
there have already been folks out there
lose their islands and
all their hard work due to save data
corruption or problems with their switch
that being said better late than never i
suppose and i'm thankful nintendo
finally added this to the game i would
suggest
all players do this first thing after
updating the game this one is actually
handled through the main menu before you
even enter your island it's a bit
confusing at first because the game kind
of leads you that maybe you shouldn't be
using it but that's simply referring to
the process of restoring your island
should something go wrong
definitely go ahead and choose the
option to enable the island backup
service
so that's it for the august update
fireworks dream suite and the island
backup service are all in new horizons
and while none of these updates are
completely mind-blowing
they're all welcome additions and i'm
happy to see nintendo keeping a steady
flow of content now for all the non-time
travelers out there we'll also see a few
new bugs and fish making their way to
the northern hemisphere this month both
the migratory locust
and rice grasshopper can be found on the
ground between the hours of 8 a.m
and 7 p.m you'll find the walker cicada
on trees between
8 a.m and 5 p.m the moray eel will be in
the sea
and available all day long the ray is
also in the sea but only
available from 4 am to 9 pm as for fresh
water the soft-shelled turtle can now be
found in rivers between the hours of 4
p.m
and 9 a.m there's also a new deep sea
creature to find and that's the flatworm
who you'll find between 4 pm
and 9 am as far as bugs and fish go for
the southern hemisphere
i'm sorry guys it's yet another sad
month because the tiger beetle is the
only new creature for you to catch
so which of these updates are you guys
most excited about let me know down in
the comments and consider giving a
thumbs up if you found this video
helpful
thanks so much for watching